bonsoir
quand j'étais une petite fille
j'avais un rêve j'avais un rêve que les
êtres humains s'entendait soit heureux
ensemble sur cette planète et c'est un
rêve qui m'a poursuivi longtemps qui a
pris beaucoup de place dans ma vie et je
vais vous expliquer comment ça s'est
incarnée mais avant de passer à vous
raconter cette histoire je voudrais
faire une petite précision sémantique
concernant les termes adultes et enfants
les thèmes que je vais utiliser adultes
enfants ne correspond pas seulement 1 à
ne corresponde vraiment à un nombre
d'année en année un nombre d'années de
vie et pas forcément à des notions de
maturité ou de sagesse un adulte de 30
ans 40 ans 50 ans peut par moment se
comporter émotionnellement comme un
enfant de trois ans et je peux en
témoigner personnellement tout comme un
jeune enfant peut parfois exprimé avec
beaucoup de sagesse et de recul
s'exprimer sur des situations même très
difficile ça aussi je les ai vécus
pourtant les deux projets dont je vais
vous parler son adresse pour l'un plutôt
à des enfants et puis pour l'autre
plutôt à des adultes alors la première
chose pour revenir à cette petite fille
que j'étais c'est que cette petite fille
que j'étais ouvert les yeux des yeux
effarés sur la réalité du monde tel
qu'il est sur cette planète
au fil des années au fur et à mesure que
j'ai grandi j'ai pris conscience de la
difficulté dans laquelle nous sommes
installés depuis maintenant bien
longtemps et j'ai aussi pu prendre
conscience au fil des années que cette
difficulté était en train de nous
rapprocher d'un mur que nous risquons
dangereusement de nous prendre en pleine
figure
donc je je suis dans une famille on se
pose beaucoup de questions et où ces
questions là sont très vivante et
forcément ça n'est pas anodin dans toute
cette histoire
j'ai voulu comprendre notamment la
violence la violence à l'égard de soi
même des autres la violence qui créent
des guerres des génocides de la
destruction et la destructivité partout
sur notre planète
la violence à l'égard de la nature du
vivant j'ai voulu comprendre cette
violence et jeunes adultes
j'ai commencé à explorer des penseurs
des pensées qui pouvait m'éclairer sur
cette violence alors bien sûr il ya
toutes sortes de théories qui existent
par rapport à la violence humaine et la
plupart des théories vont plutôt se
focaliser sur l'idée que nous sommes par
nature violent que ça fait partie de la
nature humaine et ça ça m'a pas beaucoup
intéressé par contre parce que je ne
ressentais pas simplement de résonance
avec ce type de théorie
en revanche il y à d'autres penseurs et
d'autres chercheurs qui ont abouti à
d'autres conclusions et notamment je me
suis intéressé au travail d'alice miller
d'olivier morel de gens qui en ont
déduit par leurs observations et leurs
recherches que la nature humaine est
quelque chose d'acquis que le pardon que
la violence ait quelque chose d'acquis
qui ne fait pas partie de la nature
humaine que au contraire et nous savons
maintenant grâce à la théorie de
l'attachement la nature humaine nous
porte
biologiquement à être des êtres
empathique decker giver de ceux qui
prennent soin de la vie et du vivant
donc j'ai décidé lorsque j'étais jeune
adulte jeune maman de consacrer mon
temps et mon énergie à apporter des
ressources pour préserver cette nature
humaine à travers le parentage proximale
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est à dire
être un parent sur un mode nouveau qui
écarte la violence éducative ordinaire à
la racine de la violence qui se
généralise partout à tous les niveaux de
notre société que ce soit au niveau
individuel ou collectif
donc pour réformer notre manière
d'accompagner l'enfant
j'ai choisi de créer une école dans la
ferme de mes parents qui s'est appelée
la ferme des enfants donc cette école
avait pour objectif de préserver
l'intégrité de l'enfant en lui
permettant d'être libre de ses
apprentissages en lui permettant d'être
respectés pour sortir de la relation
dominant-dominé qui a dominé pour le
coup des générations et des générations
de comportements humains
pour cela nous nous sommes d'outiller
nous avons donc quand je dis nous c'est
avec une équipe pédagogique qui s'est
formée petit à petit autour de ce projet
nous avons entrepris de nous former à la
communication non violente au pédagogie
active comme la pédagogie montessori qui
nous a été précieuse pour amorcer cette
démarche
et puis autour de l'enfant il y avait un
environnement vivant la ferme la nature
les animaux
ainsi les enfants portés par leur
enthousiasme vous pouvez aller tout
naturellement vers l'apprentissage
et puis à un moment donné nous nous
sommes aperçus que il y avait encore
bien des incohérences dans notre système
même si nous avions supprimer au maximum
la relation dominant-dominé elle si nous
avions apporté beaucoup de respect dans
la relation à l'enfant que nous nous
sommes affranchis des jugements des
notes de tout ce qui peut blesser la
construction d'un être il y avait encore
une grande question qui demeurait comme
une incohérence c'était la question du
programme scolaire
ce programme est également une violence
faite à l'enfant 1
enfin dans nos sociétés va passer dix
années de sa vie enfants et adolescents
à étudier des matières qu'il n'a pas
choisi on lui demande de focaliser son
attention de mobiliser ses élans de vie
vers des matières qui lui sont imposées
en tout cela consiste à 9 mille heures
de vie assis sur un banc des colliers
pour absorber des ex des exercices des
leçons des principes extrêmement
théorique
au demeurant ce qu'il est contraire aux
élans spontanés des enfants qu'ils ne
sont pas portés par l'enthousiasmé
naturel de l'enfant et nous nous rendons
compte de plus en plus aujourd'hui avec
l'appui des neurosciences en entre
autres choses que la manière optimale
d'apprendre c'est à prendre quand on est
porté par ses élans par l' enthousiasme
par la passion par l'intérêt et une
soirée comme ce soir évidemment en est
une démonstration vivante donc en 2016
donc l'école a été fondée en 99 donc
seize ans plus tard notre école devient
une école démocratique girafe
c'est à dire qu'elles libèrent les
enfants des programmes scolaires les
enfants qui viennent dans notre école
désormais peuvent choisir ce qu'ils font
de leur journée avec qui il la consacre
quelle activité humaine où ils vont dans
l'école une école réaménager
complètement comme une petite cité un
village où il ya une médiathèque une
salle de musique une salle de projection
du matériel pédagogique des jeux de
société une ferme des animaux la forêt
tout cela est accessible par l'enfant
donc dans notre école démocratique
girafe la communication non-violente la
bienveillance est au coeur de la
relation
c'est aussi un des principes fondateurs
de l'école une relation bienveillante ou
les conflits les problèmes vont se
régler dans une intention gagnant
gagnant où chacun est respecté dans ce
qu'il vit et n'est pas considérée ni
comme coupables ni comme volontairement
transgresseurs ou quelqu'un qui
viendrait déranger la communauté ça
c'est bien sûr la théorie il est arrivé
aussi qu'on voit les limites de notre
système et qu'on doive parfois remettre
en question certaines de certains de nos
principes mais la base c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment l'accueil inconditionnel
de l'enfant et de l'adolescent
et puis il ya une autre expérience que
nous avons mené avec mon mari laurent à
partir de 2003 nous avons engagé un
projet pour ramener la société au coeur
de notre école nous avions pour les
enfants un environnement didactique
vivent avec les pédagogies actives avec
tout le matériel qui a été rassemblé au
fil des années pour bien sûr suscité
l'intérêt de l'enfant et puis nourrir sa
curiosité et ses élans vitaux et puis il
y avait ce aussi cet environnement
naturel avec le le bois la forêt la
ferme les animaux
il s'agissait à présent de faire venir
au coeur de l'école une société mais pas
n'importe quelle société
un projet sociétal différents et c'est
ainsi que nous avons engagé la
construction d'un éco hameau au départ
ce projet s'adressait à des personnes
retraitées dans le cadre de la création
de relations intergénérationnelles et
puis au fil du temps le projet a évolué
il est devenu un éco village comme les
autres avec toutes les générations des
familles aussi qui sont venus
s'installer avec enthousiasme avec
acharnement et avec l'aide de nombreux
autres enthousiaste et acharné nous
avons engagé un vaste chantier pour
construire et une vingtaine de maisons
bioclimatiques
c'était un chantier participatif une
aventure humaine extraordinaire
inoubliable avec que de la solidarité du
partage de la joie même dans les plus
grandes difficultés
nous avons traversé toutes sortes de
difficultés matérielles financières mais
le coeur des humains était chaud et donc
nous avons abouti à la la création de 7
ce lieu d'une vingtaine de maisons
bioclimatiques faisant cela bien sûr ce
n'était pas la première fois qu'un éco
village se bâtissait nous avons rejoint
le rang des démonstrations déjà connues
à savoir que quand il ya un rêve commun
il est relativement simple de rassembler
des humains pour bâtir ensemble et puis
nous avons aussi des ombres redémontrer
1 que l'argent et disponibles et
mobilisables pour de beaux projets nous
avons aussi bâti des maisons passives
actuellement ces maisons nécessite que
très très peu de chauffage en plein
hiver donc elles sont absolument
extraordinaires sur le plan des
performances énergétiques des maisons en
ballots de paille avec des enduits à la
terre etc
nous avons aussi glané toutes sortes de
techniques pour améliorer notre
empreinte écologique diminuer notre
consommation énergétique avoir un
meilleur rapport avec l'eau récupérer
les eaux pluviales pratiquer l'auto
partage la mutualisation des équipements
comme les machines à laver ou les
outillages pour le jardin etc tout cela
fonctionne merveilleusement
en revanche il y a un défi qui ne vont
pas réussi à relever c'est celui de la
bienveillance car notre charte éthique
porté sur le respect le respect de soi
le respect de l'autre et le respect de
la nature
pour bien sûr être en cohérence avec
l'école la ferme des enfants et parce
que c'est la préoccupation
première qui m'a engagé dans ses projets
au hameau des buis donc notre éco
village j'ai vécu la situation
relationnelle la plus violente qu'il
m'ait été donné de vivre
nous sommes passés de l'utopie au
microcosme dans notre collectif même
peur même jalousie même identification à
l'argent même volonté de pouvoir qu
ailleurs nous avons retrouvé tous les
archétypes qui nous pose problème à
l'échelle macro sur cette planète qui
est la nôtre
alors c'est un constat difficile
douloureux même je peux dire que j'ai eu
le coeur brisé par cette expérience à un
moment donné et en même temps c'est une
expérience qui m'a permis de mesurer
encore une fois à l'intérieur de moi mon
appétit pour la bienveillance et comment
la violence est toxique dans nos
communautés humaines
combien elle est indigeste pour l'être
humain que nous sommes et ça m'a ramené
cette petite fille du début qui avait
cette aspiration à vivre autre chose
mais cette petite fille est là rien
d'exceptionnel elle est à l'intérieur de
chacun c'est une petite chérie comme il
ya des petits selye des petites chéries
là dans la salle tout plein à
l'intérieur qui veulent vivre autre
chose que ce qui se passe actuellement
et depuis des siècles sur cette planète
nous ne sommes pas faits pour nous
entretuer nous ne sommes pas faits pour
détruire tout ce qu'il ya autour de nous
nous ne sommes pas faits pour nous
mépriser nous haïr nous taper dessus ni
même pour retourner la violence contre
nous à travers toutes sortes
d'addictions d'impératifs de mode de vie
inappropriés à nos élans vitaux donc
cette expérience avec les adultes
m'apprend que le chemin pour aboutir est
encore long cette expérience va prendre
également qu'il ya une urgence que ce
soit allé à l'échelle d'un microcosme
comme le hameau des buis ou à l'échelle
macro et que cette urgence c'est
l'urgence de résilier alors résilié ça
peut vouloir dire en finir avec un
contrat et moi j'ai envie de dire en
finir avec cet énorme malentendu que
nous vivons depuis trop longtemps
à commencer par cette violence éducative
ordinaire que nous infligeons aux
enfants et qui bâtit une culture de la
violence les résilier c'est aussi cette
capacité d'un corps d'un organisme d'une
espèce d'un système à surmonter une
altération de son environnement
donc la première étape c'est de prendre
conscience mais elle sait aussi
surmonter et en écologie en biologie la
résilience et la capacité d'un
écosystème d'une espèce ou d'un individu
a récupéré un fonctionnement un
développement normal après avoir subi
une perturbation
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien ce mot de
résilience
cette résilience est indispensable y
arriverons nous l'avenir va nous le dire
en tous les cas dans les deux
expériences que j'ai fait il y en a une
qui m'a donné 100 % de satisfaction
c'est celle d'accompagner les enfants
avec tout le respect qu'ils méritent
avec tout l'amour inconditionnel qu il
demande que nous demandons parce que
nous sommes aussi ses enfants et de
pouvoir ainsi préserver le mieux
possible
l'intégrité de notre espèce humaine de
mon point de vue l'urgence écologique et
là la première espèce à sauvegarder
l'espèce humaine pour pouvoir
transformer petit à petit notre monde
je vous remercie
key
[Musique]
tout